[Music]
hey do you know the chicken is has a
wool hustle game what they do it's
called shady agents and you can get it
right now if you order it through the
Kickstarter program you can get it but
only for a limited time and then it's
gone so you want to get a gift for your
friend or you have maybe one of your
great enemies that you want to give
something to as a way to win them over
this is a way to do that and if you do
it very quickly you can get the game
before it's completely sold out because
it's selling fast link in the
description in unwanted divorce news
submitted by the bay loves JK Oh will
that be - BAE yeah I thought of that
that of it who wants a divorce anyway
I've met a lot of folks I don't think
they want they don't think they want one
right like no one goes into marriage
wanting a divorce
why should she I'm saying once you're in
it and they get fed up and then they
want one right but they don't really
want one everyone wants it to work yeah
but they're too [ __ ] stupid that's
why
30% of all YouTube couples go go into it
yeah knowing that they're gonna do a
divorce video later oh dude that's
[ __ ] Gino these people you know what
I'm a person that drop in a couple
months yeah it's so funny cuz what's
that what's that what the [ __ ] am I
forgetting his name Justin Bieber just
got engaged to the one chick Haley
Baldwin yeah which is really famous too
apparently I'm just waiting for the
divorce to happen he's engaged oh [ __ ]
yeah he has a mustache - looks father's
wife in front of my eyes
yeah when bride midnight like found a me
[ __ ] like that - yeah sure
a couple may have to get divorced in
order to help pay for their DARS health
care costs do you mean so they're doing
that as a business move oh I know why
their combined income is too high oh I
was thinking it's because they qualify
for a [ __ ] [ __ ] because you come from
a broken home
oh I qualify for so much [ __ ] you know
what I want a divorce now I
that's the smart advantage of that so so
so that was a Joe move that so sorry
so let me explain myself I knew what you
meant
in college and college has all these
scholarships and like financial aid and
stuff and you would try to get all the
money you can right so first I'm like
hey I'm independent you're like no
technically you're not independent 24
I'm like alright then how about this I'm
in the military and then some of them go
we don't care if you're in the military
could you get the GI bill and then I
might well hop on my pants at the bar
it'll here's some free money on my thank
you finally get the benefit you didn't
have to explain all that already cuz I
knew well there's a four other people in
the room that didn't know you right
there right in the cloud with you little
braids can't [ __ ] understand so this
family here and they're from Texas
how many piercings do you have two
things it's super Alti though
oh you ever want both ears when I was in
high school I had four down my cartilage
like that and they all got infected what
you [ __ ] disgusting [ __ ] this big
[ __ ] bump where it swallowed up the
back pin side you know the one that
hooks with the solution never took it on
yourself no wait we had some girls at
our high school and middle school and I
think even late elementary school who
just go to the bathroom and they would
be doing piercings to each other
Elementary yeah [ __ ] yeah fifth grade
[ __ ] and they're just they got caught
doing it in the bathroom I pierced my
ear in fifth grade I was in timeout in
the back corner and you know those guys
just dig in the carpet and I found a
staple and I pulled it out I pierced it
and then I had a little state ball at a
staple earring for us it was always
bellybuttons I all the girls were doing
belly buttons to each other I don't know
including coming back in the glass
crotch with ice packs and blood coming
down the shirts and [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious oh yeah alright so this couple
here they've been married for nine years
and they're happily married is just the
fact that their daughter she has this
condition where it's a developmental
it's a rare condition this day and a
developmental chromosome moles
chromosomal the disorder called Wolfe
parish or horn don't know we're not even
speaking English at this point what the
[ __ ] is going on Chester whoa whoa she
exercised ourselves anyway so this rare
from the zonal disorder her story it
sounds like you got your tongue pierced
in this morning you think what Hirshhorn
right syndrome shatter the [ __ ]
backboard of that yeah I'm stupid anyway
it's the [ __ ] shoes tip that's why I
can get that kind of height on that dunk
yeah I'm talking about
all right so this girl she's six years
old she's had developmental disability
since newborn she requires
around-the-clock care she she has vision
and hearing impairment heart and kidney
problems seizures and more a massage
this family the husband he's a veteran
he makes 40,000 a year but they have to
pay 15,000 a year for her medical
expenses ideal Smeal so if they would
get a divorce that would make the wife a
single mother a single unemployed mother
of two so then she would qualify for
Medicaid because as of right now there's
60,000 on the waiting artist was so
stupid you know what he should have done
instead of getting a divorce you just go
back into the military branch and then
the medical care would have been free
but what if he's - yeah you're stupid
I'm stupid or we got medically
discharged but I don't know the facts
yet yeah I don't know why he's living it
I don't know his age either sure they
thought about that really well if they
were this creative to get divorced how
come all these military guys get these
regretful barbed-wire tattoos they don't
they don't think about it why do they
get shine some light on this why she has
honey's like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
which one's the baby that's hurt this
one she's six and they have a
two-year-old daughter as well
oh but yeah so they're saying that with
her condition she's been pretty much a
newborn for the last six years
oh that's why she looks like a baby baby
but what do you do man like is it gonna
last your whole life what do you do got
those pictures in the back
let me see they probably did what kind
of question is that
it's just [ __ ] dubs not space are you
doing no it's cuz the pictures not even
that's why I mean but that's probably in
the middle yeah there's probably things
on the right side man I know you're
gonna make it fun of a veteran right now
no I'm not all right because you can't
do that apparently well you can if
you're a veteran what did you hear about
Sasha Baron Cohen no he's got some movie
coming out
i watch he he pretended to be a wounded
vet so that he could interview sarah
palin a bunch of people genius right and
then put everyone's blowing the [ __ ] up
going like they're mad you can't know
exactly what their pretend now they're
pretending they like you you're making
fun of the veteran it's like he's not
making fun of a [ __ ] veteran he's
like getting access to people it's
already better and approved over here
okay BAM
such [ __ ] bubbly discharge two
United States Marine Corp band comedians
doing bits like the fact that there's
blowback and it just Mitch is so boring
people don't know how boring they are I
is that because I don't understand it
but then we also make fun of like
doctors who say [ __ ] lives on a daily
[ __ ] basis yeah you know what I mean
but he's not that the joke is not the
veteran yeah that's what they don't get
right then well they don't know care
they want to use the angles yeah exactly
bombs me the [ __ ] out yeah anything
Sacha Baron Cohen I gotta watch it dude
just because I know I could I've tried
to do similar stuff like him I can't
stop laughing me too who you guys like
it's too hard
he's like sometimes he's comedy genie
Jesus where it's like we need you to
come back dude yeah we need you to come
back and do it now more than ever we
need Borat right now all right where are
you Borat we need you to expose this
[ __ ] this is the perfect is the most
perfect kind of this because on this guy
the victims are like Trump people and
he's making fun of Trump people
everyone's like all on the Trump side
they're all going like you're using
military to [ __ ] make fun of military
and psych dude that's such it's funny
how both sides call each other sensitive
as [ __ ] exactly it snowflake a spa
exactly and both sides are snowflakes
yeah don't make fun of me that's the
whole dome others together they dude
Facebook is literally a place for old
people to complain all the my [ __ ]
god dude you like they're making fun of
kids on Twitter whining their worst
them because their sister had a home
retired just [ __ ] complaining about
politics these [ __ ] right-wing [ __ ]
these no play it's like go home I don't
do something dude what's wrong with you
there's nothing to do though it's so mad
I don't follow old people on Twitter Oh
either but then other people like their
tweets or whatever retweets I mean there
are those those [ __ ] conservatives
those [ __ ] lib tards it's like I
don't know what's going on right now you
guys are so mad like what's going on -
oh isn't their sweaters that need
knitting or something trees any choppin
it's funny cuz people take anecdotal
references as facts for a whole group
always it's like they see one little guy
[ __ ] up and then it's just like it means
everybody does know it's crazy so I was
watching this video about aunt Eva right
and all these like like hate groups or
whatever so the way that media
old-school Mia constructs the narrative
is they don't get clicks and they don't
get views unless they find a demon so
even if like let's say we had a huge
peaceful rally and and there was only
like three neo-nazis or like three
auntie fungi or whatever they have to
make them the [ __ ] forefront of it
all so the rest of the world believe
like all [ __ ] because people want the
drama and they need conflict because
conflict creates story they need some
type of like bad guy a good guy and and
and this is all like a part of the game
for them to get views that's it that's
all it is
it's so shitty because it's [ __ ] with
society like in such a destructive level
now the media will blow anything up for
clicks like we all know that but that's
how that game is playing yeah no no no
that they think it's objective like
unbiased reports that's just [ __ ]
going on I mean I think our parents
generation are that [ __ ] brainwashed
but then now I feel like people waking
up they like you know what I would just
get my [ __ ] online on Twitter maybe but
this what I'm saying where everyone's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like like you can't
make fun don't make fun of me just don't
make fun of me
you can make fun of them at ha ha
they're snowflakes but then I'm
like super offended if you make fun of
my people it's how we just make fun of
everybody that's all I've been trying to
do this my whole life I want to use new
jokes all people have ruined memes for
me because old people are starting to
make beams now oh really
like you know political memes and old
people are making them I'm a cop so bad
how dare you ruin something I enjoy and
you speaking of memes like [ __ ] memes
are like hate speech in some places
oh really yeah like Pepe the Frog and
roses and white supremacist yeah I have
a pet day shirt and people like I can't
believe you support that like I didn't
know it had anything to do with you
neo-nazi you suck the Frog that just
feels bad man that's it yeah with it you
could take the meme and make it your
thing like people have taken big bird
and made him a Nazi like Big Bird is a
Nazi but the news doesn't go like big
bird he's a Nazi symbols from places
like I've seen pictures of big bird
little thing and like like like a
swastika and the hat and [ __ ] like
people co-opted big bird like give me a
[ __ ] break
[Music]